- (Thinkerview) Messieurs bonjour
- Bonjour
- (Thinkerview) Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle Thinkerview.
Présentez-vous Datagueule
Alors, qui a tiré le premier siège ?
- (Sylvain) C'est moi.
- (Thinkerview) Alors, comment tu t'appelles.
- (Sylvain) Alors Sylvain, je suis l'enquêteur et co-auteur
de cette histoire. Donc je suis celui
qui ne parle pas et ne tourne pas.
- (Thinkerview) C'est tout ?
- C'est tout.
- (Thinkerview) C'est déjà pas mal non ?
- Ouah p***, il y a du taf hein.
- (Thinkerview) Passes la parole à ton voisin de droite.
- (Julien) Merci bien (rires)
Julien Goetz,
je suis co-auteur
co-concepteur de Datagueule
et heu... Voilà. Donc moi j'écris plutôt,
j'enquête un peu et je parle un peu aussi.
- (Henri) Moi je suis Henri et je suis
co-concepteur, avec Julien, du format Datagueule
et je le réalise.
Voilà.
- (Thinkerview) Pourquoi réaliser Datagueule, Henri ?
- (Henri) Bien parce que du coup, comme je l'ai un peu conçu,
j'ai voulu le réaliser.
Et pour le pognon aussi. Non pas du tout. (rires)
- (Thinkerview) Combien çà coûte un Datagueule à faire ?
- (Henri) Heu... Alors, il y a eu plusieurs ver...
- (Julien) Alors attends. Combien çà coûte en vrai ?
Ou combien çà coûte ; comment c'est payé ?
- (Sylvain) le temps qu'on y passe en jours / homme ou...
- (Thinkerview) Profitez-en pour négocier vos salaires, les gars.
(Datagueule) Ha ouaip
- (Henri) Non, non mais en fait c'est, on ne va pas entrer
dans les détails de chiffres qui sont...
En plus, vraiment, on a pas grand chose à cacher
puisque ce serait plutôt en notre faveur.
On est payé très en deçà
de ce que nous serions payés pour d'autres formats
plus traditionnels, plus conventionnels.
Mais ce n'était pas une affaire d'argent ce programme.
- (Thinkerview) C'est une affaire de militant ?
- (Henri) C'est une affaire de conviction.
D'envie et de conviction avant tout.
L'origine du désire de ce format,
et de ce format là où on l'a diffusé,
à savoir Youtube,
là où le service public était assez peu présent
correspondait au désir effectivement de toucher des gens
qui n'avaient pas accès à un certain nombre d'informations
et nous, on pouvait essayer de leur
permettre d'y accéder avec un ton et une forme
leur permettant de...
d'être attirés par ces informations.
- (Thinkerview) Est-ce que tu penses que Datagueule joue un rôle important
pour contrer les fake news ?
- (Henri) Ce serait prétentieux de le dire ainsi,
mais on aimerait y contribuer. Voilà.
En être.
- (Sylvain) Je ne sais pas si c'est les fake news en fait qui nous intéressent.
Je pense plutôt que, enfin en tous cas, le...
Ce qu'on a en frontale, dans la colonne à droite
dans les recommandations, c'est plutôt
les Alain Soral, les Dieudonné,
la complosphère, donc plutôt le complot que les fake news.
Ce qui sont deux choses différentes quand même, structurellement.
On a beaucoup de gens, en fait, qui nous regardent.
Beaucoup d'usagers de Youtube qui nous regardent, d'internautes,
et dont on est en fait, l'une des seules sources alternatives
dans l'autre sens. C'est à dire
alternative à la fachosphère
et à des personnes qui leur mettent dans le crâne
une certaine vision du monde.
- (Thinkerview) C'est quoi la fachosphère ?
- (Sylvain) La fachosphère c'est tout le...
le système et le réseau qui s'est formé
autour d'une droite
- (Henri) l'extrême droite
- (Sylvain) qui ne dit pas son nom en fait.
Mais en gros çà correspond à l'époque où
Alain Soral à connecté Marine Le Pen
avec Dieudonné.
Et avec les ogres et toute cette galaxie là.
C'était il y a près de dix ans.
Et à l'époque on n'y a pas trop prêté attention,
sauf qu'en fait il sont "délobés" sur Youtube et c'est leur terrain.
Et aller sur leur terrain pour dire autre chose
sur les sujets qu'ils traitent eux-même et qu'ils sont parfois les seuls à traiter.
Comme le franc CFA. Quand on a fait une vidéo sur le franc CFA,
les seules autres vidéos, c'était
Dieudonné.
Et en l'occurence, dans les "comments", un tiers des "comments", c'était :
ha, Dieudonné en a parlé.
Donc moi, enfin on partage cet objectif là,
en frontale on a çà.
C'est aussi donner
une alternative à ce qu'ils croient être une alternative à l'information mainstream.
- (Thinkerview) Le pluralisme.
- (Sylvain) Oui, le pluralisme et puis l'occasion aussi de porter
une exigence factuelle
là où ils n'ont qu'une exigence en termes de discours et de forme,
qui va les porter naturellement vers des gens
qui parlent très bien mais qui disent quand même beaucoup de c**ries.
- (Henri) Julien, toi, ton avis ?
- (Julien) *Rire* Non. Mais...
mois, je voudrais revenir sur un des trucs que tu as dit, c'est
c'était une de tes questions, le militantisme...
Et cela rebondit sur le pluralisme.
Ce qui est aussi intéressant dans l'énergie
qui a porté Datagueule jusqu'ici, depuis trois ans,
c'est aussi le pluralisme et la diversité
à l'intérieur de ces trois personnes là.
C'est à dire que
quand Henri répond "oui c'est une forme de militantisme
c'est une forme d'engagement et de conviction, c'est vrai,
mais on n'a pas les mêmes.
Alors on n'est pas aux opposés
- (Henri) Pas tout à fait les mêmes. Il y a débat. Toujours.
- (Julien) Mais il y a toujours... Il y a des convictions, c'est certain,
et c'est vraiment çà qui est passionnant dans ce travail là
c'est qu'il y a des convictions qui sont diversifiées.
Ce qui fait une partie de la richesse du travail, c'est que
si on schématise, Sylvain par exemple,
va faire le gros de l'enquête Data, aller chercher
la masse la plus importante des données
70, 80 %, moi je vais faire le reste,
20, 30 %
mais je ne vais pas aller chercher les mêmes choses,
parce que je n'ai pas la même sensibilité
sur le même sujet.
Et souvent, ce n'est pas qu'on s'écharpe, mais on est
pas d'accord. On a eu le cas pas plus tard qu'hier.
On n'a pas la même vision d'un sujet,
On n'a pas les mêmes questionnements
mais cela ne nous bloque jamais en fait.
- (Thinkerview) Comment vous faites pour avoir un consensus ?
- (Julien) Mais, on ne cherche pas forcément un consensus.
On cherche à comprendre le sujet en fait.
C'est à dire que
C'est là que c'est intéressant.
On ne cherche pas à imposer une vision sur
ce que devrait être
tel sujet qu'on va traiter. Là en l'occurrence, c'est un sujet
qui a trait aux l'inégalités des sexes,
ce qu'on est en train de travailler.
- (Henri) Enorme scoop.
- (Julien) Gros gros scoop voilà.
Mais, la question, ce n'est pas de trouver la vérité sur ce sujet là.
Mais c'est de partager des questionnements. Et donc,
On ne se pose pas les mêmes questions Sylvain et moi.
Et les réponses qu'on voit traverser dans les datas
qu'on croise et dans les faits qu'on croise,
ne nous racontent pas exactement la même chose.
Et on partage nos interrogations.
Moi je dis "voilà, j'ai compris çà", Sylvain me dit
"non, je comprends plutôt çà", et du coup
on reprend les faits,
on re-mouline, et dans la discussion
on en arrive à se dire
"Ha ok ! Voilà çà y est. On a fini par comprendre la même chose.
La même question." On porte la même question au final.
- (Henri) Et la mise en forme rend compte
de cette diversité finalement.
C'est à dire que ce n'est pas un objet dogmatique Datagueule.
12 minutes aujourd'hui, 4 minutes précédemment.
C'est un objet pluriel, foisonnant, riche.
Où on peut, l'internaute le fera et nous nous le faisons déjà en amont,
puiser des pistes de réflexion, de débat
- (Sylvain) Mais au-delà de cà, le débat...
- (Henri) Enfin, ce n'est pas un tract, quoi.
- (Sylvain) Les débats ne sont pas stériles dans le sens où
il y a... L'un des aboutissements
c'est la production du programme,
mais un deuxième autre aboutissement, c'est aussi que
on ne cherche pas le consensus dans le sens où
on ne finit pas d'accord sur le même point.
Par contre, on change.
On révise nos opinions,
on progresse,
on essaye de... Enfin, à la lumière de çà,
moi j'ai changé sur ma vision de plein de trucs.
- (Thinkerview) Comme ?
Bah, moi, bosser pour Datagueule et regarder
certaines vérités factuelles
et documentées sur
la viande
principalement d'ailleurs, pas tellement sur le côté de la souffrance animale,
mais plutôt du côté de l'effet sur
le climat, sur l'eau,
sur l'enjeu également économique,
les déséquilibres nord-sud que cela impose,
la déforestation, et bien je suis devenu végétarien.
Et il y a plein de trucs comme çà, juste pour finir là-dessus
et qui nous... Même sur des tous petits trucs, mais
Julien et moi, voilà, effectivement, on n'est pas
dans cette idée d'imposer notre idée à l'autre.
On va être dans un débat, on va s'alimenter de ce que l'on a comme données
Mais après, on va arriver à un point où finalement,
Julien a une idée heum...
Nourrie de çà, de notre débat, et moi aussi.
Et on a tout les deux avancé parce que
on n'est ni l'un ni l'autre dogmatique.
Et c'est en ça qu'effectivement la notion de militantisme
elle se place plutôt au niveau de la façon qu'on a de communiquer
et ce qu'on veut faire passer comme message, la façon dont on veut le faire passer,
plutôt que sur l'idée pré-établie d'un sujet.
- (Thinkerview) Donc c'est une intelligence collaborative horizontale.
- (Henri) Alors juste une chose très importante
mais cela prolonge ce que tu viens d'amorcer, c'est à dire que
Datagueule, c'est un objet qui est en mouvement permanent.
Il est en mouvement dans sa gestion,
dans sa mise en forme, et puis il est en mouvement une fois qu'il est mis en ligne.
Puisqu'il génère... Ce n'est pas une vidéo qui
passe une fois pour toutes et basta, on passe à autre chose.
Il génère mécaniquement des commentaires, il est discuté,
les commentaires qu'on lit.
Donc il commence et il se prolonge.
Datagueule, ce n'est pas encore une fois qu'une vidéo.
C'est une vidéo
des sources
dans les métadonnées
et des commentaires.
Et c'est l'ensemble, ces trois éléments
qui créent l'objet Datagueule.
- (thinkerview) Alors en parlant des sources,
je vous pose la question à vous trois,
comment vous allez chercher vos chiffres ?
Comment vous expertisez vos sources ?
Comment vous triangulez vos sources ?
Quand il y a des sources qui sont...
on va dire en opposition frontale,
comment vous faites pour avoir un juge de paix sur ces sources là ?
- (Sylvain) Bah ! Pour le coup, heum...
Cela a beaucoup évolué aussi.
J'ai énormément appris dans cet exercice là.
Et on essaie au maximum en fait, de se baser
sur des critères de fiabilité internes aux sources.
J'ai appris, avec Julien, à
savoir quelle était la fiabilité d'une
source d'étude scientifique.
Et plus ça va, plus on va profondément là-dedans.
Et l'idée qu'il y ait des sources qui s'opposent
de manière frontale, et qui ne disent absolument pas la même chose,
en fait c'est une idée basée sur le fait
généralement que tu ne vas pas assez profond.
Quand tu vas assez profondément dans la formation de la source,
dans la production de la donnée ou d'une étude scientifique,
tu te rends compte que il n'y a jamais deux fois le même protocole,
il n'y a jamais deux fois la même population,
il n'y a jamais deux fois la même question qui est posée.
Donc, il n'y a jamais deux sondages qui s'opposent frontalement,
parce qu'ils ne sont jamais faits dans les mêmes conditions.
Donc, en soi, c'est dans ce questionnement
et je pense que la différence par rapport à
certaines visions où on peut se retrouver avec deux sources qui se contredisent,
c'est la profondeur. C'est qu'on essaye toujours d'aller
à la source de la source de la source.
Et c'est... On est, Julien et moi et Henri,
des fils intellectuels aussi de l'intertextualité
d'internet, de l'hypertexte.
Donc, on passe notre temps à remonter
d'une source à la source de la source, à la source de la source.
et ça peut nous amener très très très loin
mais dans des mindfuck de malades ou on passe
une demi-journée à chercher
ce p**in de chiffre, qui peut nous confirmer
que , effectivement,
il y a plus de filles qui échouent parce que
elles sont moins sure d'elles dans le classement Pisa
- (Julien) Ou peut-être qu'il va l'infirmer après et...
- (Sylvain)  Ou peut-être qu'on va se retrouver avec un truc qui le contre-dit.
Mais il faut l'assumer !
- (TKW) Le fact-checking.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà été fact-checkés d'une façon violente par internet ?
- (H) Récemment, il y a eu un petit...
une petite tension, amorcée par
je ne sais plus quel blogueur,
- (J) C'est parti d'un
- (S) d'un sceptique
- (H) et après relayée par...
- (TKW) Il nous faut des noms.
*brouhaha*
- (H) On est embêtés parce que on aime bien ce qu'il fait globalement.
Enfin, c'est quelqu'un d'intéressant.
Qui l'a relayé en prenant fait et cause pour ce...
Ce n'était pas du fact-cheking.
C'était plus un reproche de l'utilisation de biais.
Les faits en eux-même n'étaient pas...
De biais narratifs.
Et effectivement, donc c'est bien des biais narratifs.
Et je reviens là-dessus parce que cela prolonge un peu ce dont on a parlé précédemment.
C'est que indépendamment de cette enquête
très précise, très fouillée, obsessionnelle
qui s'ammorce
d'ailleurs en amont de
mon intervention sur le sujet
même si on me parle des sujets en amont
Au tout début bien sur, mais après je les laisse travailler
parce qu'ils font un travail que je ne sais pas faire et ils le font remarquablement.
Mais je vois l'obsession avec laquelle ils le font, ce travail.
Moi, après quand je commence à recevoir les informations, les données et les textes,
je vois naître les lignes de force.
Ce qui m'intéresse c'est les lignes de force.
C'est du pointillisme en fait. C'est de l'impressionnisme.
Tous ces petits points juxtaposés finissent par faire naître
effectivement, des tensions, des gestes narratifs.
Ou, ce qu'on pourrait appeler des biais.
Effectivement, il y a des facilités parfois.
Des facilités ou... des éléments de narration presque.
Mais qui ne se justifient que parce que, encore une fois,
c'est un Datagueule. Il ne s'interromp pas au moment où il est diffusé.
Parce qu'il propose d'être un objet qui se discute,
qui s'interroge,
qui permet de se nourrir d'autres sources et de les réinterpréter à son tour.
Et du coup, ce biais là,
on est prêt à l'assumer.
Je pense que celui-ci on l'aurait assumé différemment si...
- (J) Non, non, puis alors pour revenir sur cette question là,
on des...
effectivement, des fact-check sur les donées
et notre démarche de mettre les données en ligne,
elle part de ça. C'est à dire, allons-y
questionnons.
- (TKW) Transparence.
- (J) Voilà ! On n'a aucun problème avec ça.
On n'a aucun problème avec ça pour une raison très simple,
c'est qu'on est les premiers à penser
que rien n'est objectif, et surtout pas les données.
Et ça, c'est un point essentiel, et c'est un glissement
assez terrible qui est en train d'exister aujourd'hui,
c'est de se dire, la nouvelle vérité c'est les données.
Ce qui est une absurdité totale.
Les données sont subjectives parce qu'elles
doivent être contextualisées, elles ont un contexte d'émission.
Elles ont un contexte de création, c'est à dire
quand un set de données est créé il a un contexte de création
et quand quelqu'un se sert de ce set de données
pour raconter quelque chose, ça rajoute
un prisme de lecture.
Donc, voilà. Ce n'est pas pour autant qu'il y a manipulation.
Il faut bien dissocier les choses.
A partir d'un moment, voilà.
Si moi je raconte quelque chose que j'ai vécu,
je vais le raconter nécessairement avec ma subjectivité.
- (Tkw) J'ouvre une parenthèse
Palentir. Palentir. Ca te parle ?
- (J) Non. Comme çà, non.
- (Tkw) Un agrégateur de données ? Pas du tout ?
- (J) Non.
- (Tkw) Bon on y reviendra. Je ferme la parenthèse. Continuez.
- (J) (rires) Ha je me suis fait... J'ai un truc dans le cerveau maintenant, c'est Palentir.
Heum... Donc du coup, je reviens à ce truc là,
sur les potentiels biais, sur
cet épisode sur les industries pharmaceutiques.
Qui est un épisode que nous-même,
après l'avoir mis en ligne, on s'est dit, c'est pas le meilleur.
Voilà. Il y a des trucs qui sont fragiles et tout,
mais ça fait partie de l'exercice. On a fait 70 épisodes.
Oui, il y en a qui sont plus fragiles que d'autres,
il n'y a pas de problème avec çà.
- (S) Il y a aussi une condition de production du Datagueule en lui-même. Quelles sont les limites.
- (J) Et d'ailleurs, on a travaillé sur la constitution
d'un bouquin Datagueule, et quand on a choisi
parmi les Datagueules qu'on voulait garder
on n'a pas voulu garder celui-là exactement pour ces raisons là.
Avant même qu'on nous dise quoi que ce soit dessus mais nous-même on s'est dit
celui-là, il est un peu fragile. Il manque de nuances en fait.
Parce qu'on aime la nuance dans Datagueule et celui-là
peut-être qu'il manque un peu de nuance.
- (H) Il est un peu militant justement.
- (S) Voilà. Et c'est pas notre... Voilà. Après,
ce qui nous a été reproché là-dessus, ce n'est pas tant des reproches sur les faits
Alors évidemment la personne, je m'excuse j'ai oublié son nom,
qui a écrit çà va dire si, si c'est bien les faits.
Non, c'est effectivement les biais narratifs qui sont décriés.
C'est à dire que tout le propos était de dire "bon alors les faits sont justes,
mais il y a des biais dans la manière de les présenter.
Alors finalement, ce qui est dit, c'est quand même un peu vrai,
mais au final, il y a quand même des biais."
Ok, d'accord. Donc à un moment donné on fait quoi ?
C'est vrai ? C'est faux ? C'est... Il y a un truc... Faut...
Il y a un moment donné où je dis
on peut ouvrir un peu les... Et c'est là que je remets la subjectivité un peu
au milieu du truc c'est à dire...
- (Tkw) Je reprends la parole
Vous bossez maintenant  avec France Télévision, c'est ça ?
- (J) On a toujours bossé avec France Télévision.
- (Tkw) Est-ce que on vous a fait sentir des limites sur les sujets ?
- (DTG) Non jamais.
- Jamais. Totale liberté. On est unanimes. Que dalle.
- (TKW) Jamais ?
- (DTG) Non c'est nous qui discutons des listes de sujet, donc
- (H) Et puis on discute aussi par exemple
bien sur, chaque épisode est montré
à un responsable de France Télévision.
Alors, une petite parenthèse historique quand même sur ça.
Il le mérite.
Le programme a été initié
par "les nouvelles écritures" de France Télévision en 2014,
qui était dirigée à l'époque par Boris Razon
et c'est Renaud Allilaire
qui a été assez moteur dans le fait que ce programme existe.
Sans eux, il n'y aurait pas Datagueule.
C'est à dire qu'on l'a fait vraiment avec eux. Dès le départ.
Et avec une grande pertinence de leur part
qui est plutôt rare effectivement,
qui était que cet objet pouvait exister à condition
qu'on soit autonome.
- (J) Et ça se passe même à la limite à l'inverse,
c'est à dire qu'il y a des sujets qui nous ont été proposés par France Télévision
qu'on a pas pris.
- (TKW) Lesquels ?
- (J) Honnêtement, je ne l'ai plus en tête mais...
- (S) Ben si, il ment !
- (J) Ah bah, si tu t'en rappelles...
- (S) Non mais pour le coup, ben oui.
Et en fait on voyait derrière çà,
enfin, c'est une interprétation que j'ai mais,
il y avait une espèce de
biais qui est très classique en fait.
C'est un truc très
journalistique malheureusement dans le mauvais sens du terme
Parce qu'il y a aussi un bon sens du terme.
C'était : on pense que la communauté attend çà.
Or, il se trouve que s'il y a bien un truc qu'on a appris,
et surtout dans la dernière commande, sur la dernière saison,
la dernière fournée, et les précédentes aussi,
c'est que la surprise
est le meilleur vecteur d'intérêt
dans notre communauté.
Typiquement, l'épisode sur les notions scientifiques,
il y avait d'énormes doutes
sur, pas forcément la pertinence,
parce que la pertinence éditoriale elle était là,
on avait des éléments pour argumenter.
Mais, est-ce que ça va marcher ?
Est-ce que ça ne va pas être microcosmique ?
Ca a été le meilleur démarrage
de l'histoire de Datagueule.
CQFD donc il y a un moment où...
Alors certes, il y a la communauté derrière,
mais il y avait aussi une surprise.
A savoir, whaou, c'est quoi cette histoire ?
Ce rendement à 35 %, ces entreprises qu'on ne connait pas
et qui ont la haute main sur la recherche.
Finalement, on se retrouve, nous, avec
une exigence qui est énorme vis-à-vis de nous-même,
mais aussi la volonté, et en celà c'est militant
de parler de sujets chiants.
Et c'est clairement... Enfin moi, dans les rédactions on m'a souvent reproché ça,
de proposer des sujets chiants
et Datagueule, c'est quand même beaucoup de sujets
qui sont considérés par plein de "RS" comme chiants
parce qu'on parle pas des maîtresses de François Hollande
ou bien de la couleur du slip de Laurent Wauquiez
- (Tkw) Quelle rédaction ?
- (S) Ben moi, quand j'étais chez Marianne,
régulièrement, on m'a dit que j'avais des sujets
qui étaient chiants
et même on a eu des prises de tête
avec Ovni, des collègues qui me disaient que
j'avais des sujets chiants.
- (J) Même nous on lui a dit qu'il a des sujets chiants.
- (S) Les gaz de schiste c'est des sujets chiants tu vois
- (H) Pour être plus précis, il faut revenir à ta question
sur notre rapport avec France Télévision.
France Télévision c'est un groupe
d'audio-visuel, service public,
et majoritairement, le seul rapport
de force que nous pourrions
avoir avec eux et que l'on a eu
au tout début en tout cas, c'était de dire :
pas de censure, pas de... mais
quelle est notre cible ? Parler à une cible.
C'est un réflexe de gens de télé.
Il y a une cible, effectivement, on sait qu'à telle heure,
à tel endroit, sur telle chaîne,
on parle plutôt
aux jeunes femmes, ou aux hommes plus âgés, ou...
Et cet objectif de cible, on l'a très tôt
désamorcé.
Puisqu'il était facile de dire
et on l'a dit et on le dit sincèrement,
il n'y a pas les datas dessus.
Tatouage. Pourquoi pas? Très beau sujet,
mais on n'a pas de datas dessus.
Donc, effectivement, le recours aux datas nous permettait
et nous a permis très sincèrement
sans que ce soit une
fausse raison,
d'imposer des sujets
qui étaient tout à la fois pertinents
d'un point de vue purement éditorial, mais également
traitable sous l'angle qui était le nôtre.
A savoir y a-t-il des données ou non pour en parler ?
- (TKW) Comment vous mettez çà en image ?
Quelles sont vos inspirations ?
- (J) Alors il y a une inspiration.
Il y a un programme qui était diffusé sur la chaîne ABC
de télé publique Australienne
qui s'appelle "The beast files"
à l'intérieur d'un programme plus gros
qui s'appelait the "Hungry beast"
et donc, Boris Razon
est venu quand il a commencé à échanger avec Henri,
puis après avec moi.
Renaud aussi. Ils sont venus
avec cette référence là, en disant :
Voilà. On aime bien ce truc là, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
C'est du motion design, il y a des choses qu'on retrouve dans Datagueule
il y a une image de fin aussi. Voilà.
Donc on est partis de ce... C'était un peu notre
point de départ quand on a commencé à conceptualiser Datagueule.
On est parti de là et après on a pris la tangente
pour se dire, nous, qu'est-ce qu'on a envie de faire
avec un programme de motion design qui met des datas en forme,
qui essaie de révéler quelque chose à la fin,
et c'est comme çà qu'on est partis sur une sorte de mécanique
où voilà, l'idée était de se dire
ok, il y a plein de datas partout qui sont présentés à chaque JT
dans chaque "une" de canard en permanence
mais à quel moment on les corréle entre elles et on offre une perspective
on pose une perspective qui encore une fois n'est pas une perspective
dogmatique mais qui est une perspective de questionnement.
- (TKW) Est-ce que vous avez eu des menaces ?
- (H) Pas encore. Après cette émission, probablement.
(S) Mais on attend avec impatience.
D'ailleurs, si vous voulez nous menacer...
- (H) Non non non non (rires)
- (TKW) Donc pas de menace parce que vous traitez des sujets un peu touchy
- (S) Mais non parce que tout est public en fait. C'est çà qui est génial. C'est que souvent...
- (H) Il y a eu des tensions avec Frontex par exemple,
à l'occasion de l'épisode sur Frontex
- (DTG) oui oui oui.
- (H) Il y a eu des retours mais là,
- (TKW) Il faut expliquer Frontex.
- (H) Frontex, c'est l'agence européenne qui s'occupe de surveiller les frontières.
Qui coordonne la surveillance des frontières.
- (H) qui n'est pas exempte de tout reproche dans la crise...
Dans les milliers, les dizaines de milliers de morts aux frontières de l'Europe.
C'est un sujet qu'on a abordé dans la première ou deuxième saison
Datagueule.
Frontex est monté au créneau, il n'était pas content de ce qu'on pouvait dire.
On peut les comprendre, en même temps on maintient ce que nous disions.
Il est encore en ligne.
Et là, France Télévision a joué très joliment son rôle.
C'est à dire que Frontex s'est adressé à France Télévision qui est quand même le diffuseur et
le co-producteur du programme.
France Télévision a fait obstacle et on n'a pas du tout été inquiété.
On est vraiment accompagné par France Télévision. Sur ce cas d'école par exemple,
on pourrait oublier parce qu'il y a longtemps, mais quand même, ils se sont...
Il est important de savoir que le diffuseur, le service public français, est
capable de s'opposer à
Frontex qui dit "supprimez cette vidéo tout de suite"
- (TKW) Tu veux ajouter quelque chose ?
- (H) C'était pas loin. Non non non, c'était pas loin.
- (J) Des distensions. C'est pas du tout ce qui a été dit.
- (H) C'est dire effectivement, combien la mémoire est subjective. Voilà.
- (J) Donc, il y a eu une réaction, effectivement, de Frontex qui
trouvait ça mal venu de la part des services publics de
prendre en charge la diffusion d'un tel programme.
Ca s'arrête là. Après il n'y a pas eu de menaces de la part de Frontex.
- (H) Non, pas de menaces, mais une demande quand même de modifier l'objet.
- (S) Une réaction diplomatique, on va dire.
- (H) C'est particulier, parce que comme c'est sur le net, c'est pérenne.
On peut voir ce programme encore aujourd'hui.
Et là aussi, les réseaux, Youtube, bouleverse les usages
et surprend les institutions.
C'est à dire que ce qui a été dit, et qu'on assume toujours est encore en ligne et accessible aujourd'hui.
- (J) Et après, c'est peut-être aussi l'une des limites de Datagueule. C'est à dire que
les datas n'étant jamais objectives et étant dans un monde mouvant, bougent
et il y a des choses qu'on a pu faire dans certains épisodes les plus datés,
- (S) Il y a trois ans
- (J) Qui ne sont plus forcément... Les constats ne sont plus forcément aussi valables,
ou en tous cas les rapports de force sont en train de bouger.
Et dans 3, 4, 5 ans, cela aura encore bougé.
- (H) Mais l'internaute est capable de le comprendre.
Il voit que la mise en ligne date de 2014 et il peut réaliser aussi
qu'un trajet a été fait depuis.
- (S) Mais après, ce serait absurde que quelqu'un vienne nous poursuivre.
Parce que fondamentalement, il n'y a aucun terrain pour de la diffamation.
90 % des données qu'on utilise sont disponibles. Voir plus généralement.
Sont disponibles en ligne.
Ou dans des bouquins qui sont dans beaucoup de bibliothèques en France.
Et du coup, on n'a aucune exclu. Et parfois, on a des commentaires un peu perplexes genre :
mais comment ? On vous autorise à dire des trucs comme çà ?
Parce qu'il y a une espèce de fascination, et ce que ne comprennent pas certains internautes
c'est que ce qu'on fait, finalement, c'est une analyse différente,
et éventuellement, on traite à un autre niveau de profondeur
des données qui sont disponibles,
le rapport, plutôt que certains journalistes qui,
dans des injonctions extrèmement
brutales et contraintes
de produire très vite, vont lire l'introduction du rapport,
moi je me "l'enquille" et Julien, il va aussi se taper 2 ou 3 chapitres
pour compléter ce que j'ai lu.
Et cette différence de profondeur finalement nous amène à trouver des trucs
qui sont dans ces rapports. Mais les rapports en question, on les télécharge, on met les liens.
ils sont accessibles. Et on propose même aux internautes de venir,
enfin, que... Qu'ils vérifient les vérificateurs.
Vous, vous pouvez vérifier les vérificateurs.
On met tous les outils pour vérifier.
Avec même les citations qui correspondent au truc. Vous pouvez reprendre la phrase,
prendre le lien, et vous allez voir, et vous allez chercher pour retrouver le truc.
Donc, il n'y a pas de terrain pour qu'on nous poursuive.
Tout ça est public.
- (J) Il y a un truc tout bête aussi sur cette question là, de
On utilise des choses déjà documentées parce qu'on n'est pas dans une logique d'investigation  pure,
comme peuvent l'être... On connait bien, par exemple, les gens de Cash investigation
puisqu'ils sont produits par Première ligne, qui est co-producteur de Datagueule.
Ils ont un an d'enquête.
Un an d'investigation pour aller chercher de la donnée, pour sortir des choses.
Et cette année d'enquête leur donne une vraie légitimité juridique
si jamais telle entreprise décide de les attaquer
en disant "il y a diffamation", et bien voilà. En retour, les journalistes face à un tribunal, peuvent dire
"Voilà on a passé un an, on a appelé untel, untel et untel.
Nous on a deux à quatre jours d'enquête, en fait.
Donc en deux à quatre jours d'enquête, on ne fait pas des miracles.
On est obligés de prendre des choses qui ont déjà été sorties, vérifiées,
des jugements qui ont été rendus.
On ne peut pas se permettre de prendre des choses dont on n'est pas surs
parce que si jamais une entreprise comme Danone, comme n'importe qui,
qui a une grosse force de frappe juridique
- (S) Financière aussi. Qui a les moyens.
- (J) C'est très compliqué pour nous pour justifier
parce qu'on n'a pas la profondeur derrière
de dire "voilà, ça fait un an qu'on enquête et on a appelé toute la terre" pour justifier ce truc là.
- (H) Mais on met à jour les systèmes.
On ne fait pas de focus sur des points particuliers
qui nécessiteraient effectivement de double-croiser les sources etc...
C'est à dire qu'on a la possibilité effectivement, de mécaniser...
- (TKW) Je vais reprendre la parole.
Je vais vous poser une question un peu personnelle.
A force de manier toutes ces datas, à force de vous faire des injections de connaissance.
A travailler ce type de problématiques comme les migrants,
le nombre de cadavres en méditerranée,
des sujets vraiment hardcore.
Comment vous gérez psychologiquement, à votre échelle personnelle ?
Et aussi comment vos proches vous considèrent ou vous perçoivent
avec cette conduite autistique avec l'information,
cette boulimie d'information.
Comment vous gérez. Vous faites de la méditation ? Vous faites quoi ?
Vous faites du sport ?
- (S) Ouaip. Alors ça faudrait penser à la méditation, éventuellement.
- (DTG) La méditation en pleine conscience.
- (J) Je pense que le mot boulimie est très juste.
C'est à dire qu'il y a un truc qui nous rapproche profondément tous les trois,
c'est qu'on est d'une exigence, chacun dans notre domaine de travail,
assez excessive, c'est clair.
Donc, on est dans la boulimie de...
Effectivement, Sylvain fait 70 % d'enquête.
Il me livre un doc avec 40, 50 parfois 60 pages de documents.
Je pourrais me contenter de lire et de faire le script à partir de çà. Rien que ça, déjà,
ça lui a pété les neurones, ça me ferait sauter les miens en même temps.
Mais je ne peux pas arriver à écrire quelque chose que je n'ai pas compris.
Donc quand il me met trois paragraphes de citation d'un rapport, je vais être obligé
d'aller lire les deux pages qui précèdent et les trois qui suivent, du rapport
pour être sûr que je comprends ce qu'il a écrit en fait.
Et que je comprends les implications.
Donc, en fait, on a effectivement une vraie boulimie
et la manière dont on gère ?
On est révolté très souvent,
(S) H24 à peu près
(J) on est touché par plein de choses en permanence,
on est en....
(TKW) Vous faites pas trop chier dans les dîners avec des amis ?
(S) Si ! Mais moi en tous cas on me le fait remarquer régulièrement. Je finis par avoir ce biais
justement, du sceptique.
C'est à dire, je me retrouve dans des discussions avec, par exemple
une fille qui me dit "ha oui mais quand même, si tu manges 500 calories de boulgour,
c'est mieux que si tu manges 500 calories de croissants.
Je lui dit "ben non parce que 500 calories, c'est la même unité de mesure donc
c'est autant d'énergie qui est absorbée donc les deux vont te faire grossir autant.
Il y en a un qui est plus sain, l'autre pas c'est un autre...
- (H) Il fait pas chier, il est chiant en fait.
- (S) Et le fait est que je suis devenu vraiment sceptique.
Je ne suis pas diététicien, je comprends maintenant comment il fonctionne,
même si je pense que ça se joue des fois sur d'autres niveaux.
Je respecte tout à fait la démarche.
Mais c'est vrai que du coup, il y a un truc juste très concret
à la fin de chaque "enquête"
même si je continue à enquêter parallèlement à l'enquête de Julien
pour compléter. Je lui dit "bon écoute.
Voilà le doc, mais j'ai relevé quelques points
qu'il faut que j'éclaircisse. Et les quelques points, des fois,
c'est une liste de 80 trucs.
Et çà va de la petite pétouille de
est-ce qu'on a l'année exacte dans la période où on a
relevé cette population et ce pourcentage,
jusqu'à éclaircir la notion de "marketing féminin".
- (TKW) Tu connais Monk ?
- (J) Thelonius ? Ou...
- (TKW) Non Monk.
- (S) Thelonius oui. La série ?
- (TKW) La Série.
- (S) Alors je sais que Henri en a une collection. Je ne l'ai pas regardée.
- (H) C'est un enquêteur autiste.
- (TKW) Oui tu as une petit syndrome Monk quand même
- (S) J'arrive à débrancher. Mais simplement, j'avoue que ça nous obsède. Et par ailleurs,
pour finir là-dessus, il y a des moments où
il y a un peu le syndrome du journaliste
enquêteur transversal, à savoir
tu regardes une pièce et là, tu vois flotter les faits que tu as relevé
à chaques fois, sur plein de trucs
- (J) Il a un petit côté Carrie Mathison
- (S) Ca peut être un peu obsessionnel.
- (J) Après, on n'a pas les mêmes...
- (H) Non. En effet, faut comprendre. Pour répondre à cette question, il faut distinguer.
On ne réagit pas de la même manière. On n'a pas la même fonction.
Majoritairement, moi c'est beaucoup plus facile.
Même très majoritairement. Même si je participe un tout petit peu en amont
au choix des sujets, aux discussion sur les sujets, mais très très peu.
En réalité, moi mon boulot c'est de
formaliser le travail d'enquête et d'écriture qui a eu lieu précédemment.
Donc, c'est beaucoup plus positif parce que je pends cette matière,
je la manipule, j'en fais un objet audio-visuel,
que j'offre après à la communauté, aux internautes,
à ceux que çà intéresse.
Mais c'est beaucoup plus facile à supporter.
Puisque, effectivement, je suis révolté, indigné, touché, troublé.
Evidemment ! Mais ma fonction me permet de
mettre cette énergie là
dans l'objet que j'offre aux autres.
- (J) Et entre les deux...
- (H) Toi tu souffres.
- (J) Moi je suis dans la compression.
Et c'est vrai que c'est une autre forme de souffrance.
Mais c'est que les 40 ou 80 pages de Sylvain, moi je dois en faire 1 page en fait.
Et les 40 pages d'enquête me passionnent. C'est çà qui est terrible en fait.
C'est vraiment, je suis... J'aime ses enquêtes,
j'aime ces sujets, j'aime leur complexité. C'est çà qui est horrible.
J'adore cette complexité du monde qui nous entoure.
Que ce soit sur le sujet de la fiscalité, sur le sujet de la pauvreté,
sur le sujet environnemental,
tout est complexe. On ne peut pas résumer à aucune phrase qu'on entend si souvent sur
tous les plateaux de télé où on essaye de résumer à une "based line" des problèmes
qui sont vraiment compliqués à comprendre.
Et il faut que j'arrive... Enfin c'est pas qu'il faut, mais je m'oblige, parce que je ne peux pas faire autrement,
à rendre compte de cette complexité dans une page,
et à essayer d'avoir un peu ce...
- (H) Sans rien perdre de l'essentiel.
- (J) cette saveur là. Et çà, vraiment, c'est un moment très
- (TKW) Est-ce que vous allez sur le terrain toucher vos datas ?
- (J) C'est-à-dire ?
- (S) En quatre jours ?
- (TKW) Est-ce que par exemple, sur le sujet des migrants, au sujet du cannabis, au sujet de l'évasion fiscale,
- (S) Non.
- (H) Pas dans le cadre de notre activité.
- (TKW) Non, mais à titre personnel, est-ce que
- (H) Probablement, parfois, bien sûr.
- (TKW) Parfois, vous revoyez vos données dans la vraie vie ?
- (H) Dans la vie.
- (S) Bien oui. Tout le temps.
- (J) Oui, bien sûr.
- (H) Mais c'est aussi la vraie vie, les données.
- (S) La vraie vie, enfin tu vois, on fait un truc sur la viande. Enfin...
- (J) Après on n'est pas sur des enquêtes de terrain. Donc voilà, mais...
- (S) On n'est pas sur des enquêtes de terrain. Mais la vie nous amène à re-croiser çà.
- (H) Mais la vie est sur le terrain, en tous cas.
- (S) j'ai été invité comme çà à un congrès,
enfin à une conférence à Lampedusa.
Du fait de l'épisode sur les migrants.
Et ce qui n'était que des données, finalement, c'est devenu des gens, c'est devenu des militants,
c'est devenu des gens qui produisent les données, c'est devenu les gens qui aident les migrants.
Et c'est devenu l'endroit emblématique.
Et c'est vrai que cela fait quelque chose quand tu vois effectivement les données
retomber sur terre.
- (J) Et ce qui nous nourrit aussi là-dedans,
on n'a pas le temps, malheureusement, d'être dans l'enquête de terrain,
Mais on a quand même une passe dans l'enquête où on va
systématiquement chercher du côté des écrits de sociologie.
Et cette passe là elle est importante parce qu'elle nous rapporte ce terrain là.
Contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser,
des sociologues, ne sont pas des gens qui vivent
enfermés dans une université. C'est des gens de terrain,
qui vont étudier ce qui se passe
et qui vont au plus proche. Et lire ces écrits de sociologie
sur les sujets, généralement ne nous amène pas de datas,
mais pour moi c'est toujours important parce que cela m'amène de la compréhension humaine.
Et au final, Datagueule, ce n'est pas un programme de datas, c'est un programme
de questionnement de l'humain en fait. De comment on vit en société,
de quels sont nos mécanismes de vivre ensemble.
Les datas nous permettent de porter des coups de projecteur et d'interroger çà,
de faire émerger des choses, mais ce qu'on questionne au fond,
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fout en fait. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Comment on se parle ? Comment on fait du commerce ?
Comment on traite la terre autour de nous, comment...
Voilà, c'est vraiment l'envie de base qu'il y a derrière çà,
c'est de questionner çà.
- (S) De n'apporter aucune réponse.
- (J) Et surtout, voilà, ne pas chercher
- (S) De vraiment apporter un maximum de questions,
mais d'autres questions que celles qu'on se pose habituellement.
- (J) Voilà, d'essayer d'aller tourner un peu le projecteur
pour voir autrement, essayer de... Bon c'est un peu une lubie du moment pour moi, mais
quand on dit qu'on va être 9 milliards en 2050,
ok, tout le monde part tête baissée, il faut faire moins d'enfants
surtout dans les pays pauvre,
il faut encore produire plus pour l'agriculture,
parce que sinon on n'aura jamais assez à manger pour tout le monde...
Voilà. Et d'un coup, nous notre démarche, ça va être de se dire : attendez, attendez.
On produit déjà pour 12 milliards, donc ça veut dire que le problème c'est pas la production
agricole, l'empreinte carbone, là où il y a le plus haut taux de fécondité
c'est la plus faible, donc ça veut dire que ce n'est pas une question de fécondité
donc, ça se passe à un autre endroit.
Donc, si ça se passe à un autre endroit, qu'est-ce qu'on va chercher ?
Et cette complexité là, elle est trop peu racontée, et nous elle nous passionne.
- (TKW) Là, on est en période électorale,
quand vous écoutez les...
- (J) On fait des bonds, mais on fait des bonds !
- (S) C'était très drôle. Pendant les débats de la primaire,
j'avais en parallèle des sms de Julien et de Henri
qui tombaient, et je leur répondait :
t'as vu, il a dit çà, mais tu te rends compte ?
Comment est-ce qu'il peut dire çà sur le travail, encore,
en 2017 ? Après tout ce qui est sorti !
Il pourrait citer Stiegler. Oui mais tu comprends, c'est compliqué.
Et on avait des échanges, comme çà.
- (J) Non, mais on peut avoir un stéréotype.
Voilà. Au jour où on enregistre cette émission, là maintenant,
au moment où on se parle, on est au lendemain du débat
(histoire de redonner le repère spacio-temporel)
on est au lendemain du débat Hamon / Valls
de la primaire de la gauche, du parti socialiste
- (H) D'une partie de la gauche
- (J) Oui, d'une partie de la gauche.
- (S) D'une partie du parti socialiste.
- (J) Et donc, il s'est passé à un moment donné, ce truc qui moi m'a fait bondir,
ou Valls, sur la question du revenu universel, a dit :
" Je suis le candidat de la fiche de paie, Monsieur Hammon, vous êtes le candidat de la fiche d'impôts.
Mais çà, c'est vraiment tout ce qui me fait vomir en fait.
C'est à dire on réduit la réalité
à deux phrases.
Et la question n'est même pas de savoir, est-ce que moi, individuellement,
je soutiens ou pas le revenu de base.
En tous cas, je me suis renseigné dessus, c'est un truc qui me questionne, qui m'interroge
et çà n'est pas résumable à çà.
C'est faux. Le revenu de base, c'est quelque chose qui cherche à,
et çà, c'est un truc qu'on entend jamais,
qui cherche à dé-correler le revenu de l'emploi.
C'est même pas le travail ! C'est de l'emploi. Et çà, mais...
- (TKW) J'ouvre une parenthèse : si je te dis que le revenu de base
favorise l'émergence d'une intelligence artificielle forte ?
- (J) Alors, il faudrait que tu développe ta pensée,
pour que je puisse comprendre en quoi ? Quels sont les mécanismes ? Et éventuellement, discuter.
Tu me dis ça comme ça, c'est une affirmation. Ok.
Il faut que l'étayer, pour que je puisse comprendre en quoi ça émergerait...
Ca aiderait à l'émergence d'une intelligence artificielle forte.
Est-ce que c'est parce que çà libère du temps ? Je n'en sais rien en fait...
- (TKW) Je t'enverrai le lien, ou on le mettra sur nos réseaux.
Il y a eu une audition, au Sénat, sur...
- (J) Haaa... C'est Laurent Alexandre qui a... ?
- (TKW) Exactement, oui.
- (J) Je n'ai pas encore eu le temps encore d'écouter son...
- (S) J'ai vu passer çà, je lui ai envoyé sur slack.
Voilà. On se partage aussi des trucs parce que...
- (J) Ca fait partie des vidéos que je veux regarder parce qu'elle m'a interpellé.
- (TKW) Parenthèse fermée, ok.
On en était à quoi, là ?
- (S) On parlait du débat
- (J) A la complexité. Voilà tu nous a envoyés sur les élections,
la période électorale, on a rebondit tout de suite parce que...
- (H) Datagueule, c'est un programme éminemment politique.
Donc, dans ce temps fort politique
des mois qui précèdent les élections présidentielles,
c'est dommage que ce soit juste quelques mois tous les cinq ans,
évidemment, qu'on est... Qu'on se sent...
Impliqués, interrogés.
Mais on réagit quotidiennement à tout ce qui peut se dire parce que
effectivement, enfin, on parle de politique.
(brouhaha)
- (S) ...c'est qu'on ne fait pas d'actu. Or, il se trouve que systématiquement, l'actu nous rattrape.
Et l'exemple type, c'est que
on a décidé de faire un épisode sur l'assistanat.
- (H) Les systèmes sont d'actu.
- (S) Voilà, évidemment ! Le système est toujours d'actu, par définition.
Les systèmes, et en l'occurrence tous ceux qu'on décortique.
Et l'assistanat, on l'a défini, il y a très longtemps,
avant que çà monte, évidemment, que çà soit encore pire.
Et moi, sincèrement, je le dis sans fausse pudeur,
moi, j'ai chialé en lisant certains trucs que j'ai lu.
Des rapports, mais vraiment absolument révoltants sur
la condition de certaines personnes et la raison pour laquelle ils ne demandaient pas.
L'humiliation sociale ou alors la conscience, non la conviction pardon,
que tu n'as pas droit à certaines choses. Ou alors l'idée que si tu les demandes,
alors tu es un mendiant.
Il y a çà. Et je ne peux pas m'empècher de me dire
que tous ces gens qui parlent de l'assistanat en mentant!
Parce que en l'occurrence, ils le savent. C'est çà la différence entre le mensonge et l'erreur.
C'est que Laurent Wauquiez, il est président du conseil régional.
Il sait. Il a les chiffres. Il a été au conseil général, il a les chiffres.
Il sait combien on distribue. Il sait combien de gens
demandent et ne demandent pas.
La fraude à la carte vitale etc... Et effectivement, on voit,
comme çà, des mots qui sont balancés, et qui créent des mythologies intellectuelles.
Comme l'assistanat.
Alors qu'on se rend compte qu'en fait les "non recours",
les personnes qui ne demandent pas ce à quoi ils ont droit
couvrent, mais plusieurs fois,
la petite fraude des revenus garantis
et de la sécurité sociale
qui elle, correspond à une fraction infinitésimale
de la grosse fraude aux impôts, et notamment aux impôts sur les activités d'entreprises.
Et avec Julien, on se tape çà dans la gueule régulièrement, et
çà nous hérisse parce que on est dans cette profondeur là, et on y est
dans le profondeur factuelle, mais aussi émotionnelle.
- (J) Mais oui, et je reviens à ce truc d'humain, parce que c'est un leitmotiv permanent.
Mais quand le revenu de base arrive sur (Je garde cet exemple là) sur la table.
Les seules question, et on a une vraie carence journalistique là-dessus, je trouve.
Les seules questions c'est : combien çà va coûter ?
Et juste on laisse passer les critiques qui disent : c'est la fin du travail.
Mais personne, pas un journaliste, sur aucun débat, va dire :
attendez, du coup, çà veut dire quoi ? Est-ce que c'est
tout le monde accrédite en fait, sans poser de question, l'idée que le revenu universel ce serait
toucher de l'argent à rien foutre.
Mais c'est d'une bêtise infinie !
- (S) C'est insupportable.
- (J) C'est quelqu'un qui ne s'est pas posé deux secondes pour réfléchir
à quoi çà va servir. Si vous discuter avec n'importe qui qui porte cette question là
Tout le monde va vous expliquer que c'est là, notamment,
que ça libère du temps pour créer des choses.
Pour fabriquer, pour choisir, pour travailler vraiment.
- (TKW) Un peu comme chez google, non ?
- (J) Heu sur le... C'est quoi ? C'est un jour par semaine ?
- (S) Oui, le cinquième.
- (TKW) Quelque chose comme çà, oui.
Effectivement, ils développent des trucs.
Après, eux, ils le développent avec une autre logique.
- (TKW) Expliques pour les auditeurs.
- (J) Google laisse, alors je ne peux pas donner de chiffres réels parce que je ne connais pas,
laisse une part du temps de ses employés
pour développer des projets totalement personnels
et complètement décorrélé de leur activité chez Google.
Ca fait partie du contrat. Ils sont payés.
C'est un jour payé pareil. Je crois que c'est un jour par semaine.
Où il peuvent développer le projet qu'ils veulent, pour leur propre créativité.
Le revenu de base intègre un peu cette idée là,
si ce n'est que, en fonction... Et c'est celà qui est compliqué avec le revenu de base.
Encore une fois, c'est un concept complexe.
Le revenu de base, il est défendu par les ultra-libéraux
comme des gens de gauche.
Donc il peut être totalement destructeur d'une protection sociale,
c'est vrai, certains l'entendent comme çà.
Et il peut être en même temps complètement porteur
d'une solidarité complètement nouvelle et contributive,
et ouvrir à d'autres choses.
Mais pour çà, il faut juste à un moment donné,
accepter une forme de complexité du monde quoi.
- (S) C'est pareil avec les questions climatiques.
Au départ, on a renvoyé sans arrêt à la dette.
Et il y a une phrase de Pujadas qui m'a fait hurler.
A savoir : avec vous, c'est fromage ou dessert.
- (TKW) Et truite saumonée.
- (S) P*** non mais. Avec vous c'est fromage ou dessert ! Mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut pas dire comme...
Ha bah, quoi ? Vous dites que çà va coûter cher d'éviter à nos enfants d'avoir des cancers
à cause de la pollution au diesel ?
Ecoutez, franchement, là !
J'hésite quoi. Je suis un peu...
Ca va me coûter cher. Non mais sans déc*** !
On est en 2017, la COP 21 il en a fait des caisses,
et maintenant il nous raconte çà ?
Et une demi-heure plus tard, il dit :
l'état d'urgence, on ne va peut-être pas en parler, c'est un sujet un peu technique.
Sans déc*** ! Et la dette c'est quoi ?
C'est une vaste blague ! Non mais faut arrêter le délire quoi.
Donc, l'état d'urgence c'est un peu technique, parce que en gros
hoter des libertés, bon c'est pas... On ne veut pas trop en parler.
Par contre, supprimer un maximum de postes de fonctionnaires,
çà, c'est un truc, on veut en parler beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup, tout le temps, tout le temps, tout le temps.
Et à aucune moment, c'était l'expression de...
Heum... Je ne sais plus...
un économiste atterré,
qui disait : vous vous rendez compte ?
Vous avez un débat aujourd'hui,
où les gens, c'est des énonomistes
qui parlent d'économie, c'est des économistes qui ont eu un AVC.
Ils ne voient plus que la colonne des dépenses.
- (TKW) Frédéric Lordon, non ?
- (S) C'est Lordon ! Exactement ! Ils sont hémiplégiques, ils ne voient plus que la colonne des dépenses.
Ils ont oublié que, bien parfois,
en donnant de l'argent à certaines choses,
et bien on en retirait un bénéfice.
Alors, ce n'est pas un bénéfice avec des euros,
avec un chiffre d'affaires,
avec de la croissance et ce genre de mythe, des mythologies, ou des systèmes comptables.
C'est du bénéfice humain,
social. Un intérêt social.
Et çà, l'intérêt social *paf*.
- (TKW) Bon, il nous reste 15 minutes ensemble, çà passe vite.
Donc on va vous poser des questions un peu choc maintenant.
Henry ?
- (H) Oui.
- (TKW) Comment tu vois l'avenir ?
Rose ? Pas rose ?
Racontes un peu.
- (S) On vous laisse.
- (TKW) Ohh vous avez la même question après hein... Rassurez-vous.
- (H) Comment je vois l'avenir ? Sincèrement ?
- (TKW) Il y a intérêt que ce soit sincère. Tu es sur Thinkerview.
- (H) Oui oui il y a un débat entre moi et moi là, qui se passe dans ma petite tête.
Il y a une part de moi qui a envie de dire :
écoutes, il n'y a pas de raison que çà se passe mal,
puisqu'il suffit que
tout le monde fasse des choses d'une manière ou d'une autre,
et dans un sens plutôt positif et voilà, çà peut, voilà !
Cette partie là, cette
dimension optimiste
dans ma tête est rapidement calmée par
le plus réaliste, dès lors que
dès l'ors qu'on observe le monde
sujet par sujet, thématique par thématique, tranche par tranche,
on a l'impression quand même que tous les voyants sont au rouge,
et que le cynisme, que l'obsession de l'argent, que
le commerce, le rapport de force
dans l'économie et le commerce,
nous met nous, humains dans une
situation impossible,
et que ce sont des tendances très forte.
Il va falloir faire vraiment beaucoup pour inverser cette tendance
qui nous mène dans le mur, qui est une tendance très morbide
c'est une tendance qui me fascine dans la logique.
Dans les logiques commerciales, du capitalisme,
enfin celles qui sont obsédées par les colonnes de dépenses et de profits.
C'est que c'est morbide, quoi. Que cela crée de la mort.
Fondamentalement cela crée de la mort.
Quel que sujet que ce soit. Là, récemment,
sur l'agriculture industrielle,
cela tue les sols, cela tue les gens avec les pesticides
En premier, cela tue les paysans et leurs enfants,
et comme cela, avec des tendances morbides on peut difficilement être optimiste.
- (TKW) Même question.
- (J) Heum...
Moi, je suis d'un naturel plutôt optimiste.
Donc, je reste optimiste.
- (S) Diversité.
- (J) Exactement. Après, comment je vois le futur ?
En fait, je le vois surtout au présent.
Je m'intéresse surtout au présent et au passé.
Et j'essaie de ne pas trop m'interroger
trop loin sur le futur.
J'essaye juste de faire rencontrer le présent et le passé pour... On verra ce qui se passe, mais
ce qui est sûr, c'est que le futur, en tous cas
si on veut sortir un peu de ces histoires là, c'est...
c'est sûr que cela va être un futur un peu en lutte
et pourtant, je ne suis pas un militant point levé du tout.
Mais je pense qu'il y a des luttes de...
Moi, je les vois... Encore une fois, c'est un point de vue très individuel à l'intérieur du trio.
Moi, je les vois comme des luttes de pensées en fait. C'est à dire de
comment on pense le monde. Et je m'en rends compte parce que
je vois des penseurs, je pense à Bernard Stiegler, par exemple,
qui me fascine parce que c'est un philosophe
et que, quand il définit des mots et des concepts,
je vois un boxeur, en fait.
Je vois un boxeur qui veut s'emplafonner la Silicon Valley,
qui veut s'emplafonner le transhumanisme,
qui veut s'emplafonner des concepts qu'il trouve dangereux
pour l'avenir de la société.
Pour ce qu'ils créent. Parce que ces concepts là,
ont des répercussions concrètes dans des actions d'entreprises,
dans des actions qui touchent la société.
Et je pense que la période dans laquelle on est,
est fascinante pour cela. Parce qu'il y a des choses
qui émergent de cela en fait. C'est à dire que
il y a un combat de pensées
qui est assez enthousiasmant, parce que
il y a des choses qui émergent. On a des
complexités auxquelles il faut arriver à faire face.
Et il faut sacrément se creuse
la tête pour arriver à trouver des choses qui vont permettre de
faire en sorte que ce soit vivable pour tout le monde.
Et ce qui est passionnant, c'est que je sens qu'il y a plein de gens qui réfléchissent à cela en fait.
C'est à dire que ce n'est pas des petits cénacles fermés
il y a une pensée ouverte, très forte,
très partagée, très passionnée, qui part dans...
Qui parfois se contre-dit, parfois s'emplafonne, mais ce n'est pas un problème.
Mais il y a un truc très très fort
au coeur duquel nous nous immergeons tout le temps,
c'est pour cela que c'est si juste d'être présent sur Youtube,
et d'être présents sur les réseaux numériques d'une manière générale.
Parce que cette agitation, elle traverse tout cela, il n'y a pas de...
- (TKW) A toi.
- (S) Alors moi, pour aller un peu dans la continuité de Julien,
j'ai eu ces derniers temps quelques épiphanies.
Notamment, par rapport à l'éducation populaire.
Et je pense qu'on est dans cette démarche aussi avec Datagueule.
J'étais émerveillé
- (TKW) l'éducation populaire, un peu comme Michel Onfray ou
- (S) Non, mais parce qu'on est en janvier, tu parles d'épiphanie, ben oui, c'est normal.
- (S) On n'a pas tiré les rois.
- (J) Pardon.
- (S) Et... On les a décapités ! Et heu...
- (H) Nous sommes les rois mages.
- (S) Non, l'éducation populaire
- (TKW) Alors Melchior raconte nous tout.
- (S) C'est dans cette démarche... En fait pour moi il y a cette notion
à laquelle, j'espère, Datagueule participe.
Je l'ai vu participer. Parce que on fait des projections, on est invités à des conférences
et en soi, je m'en bat les c*** d'aller faire notre pub
ce qui m'intéresse, c'est d'aller voir les personnes qui nous regardent et de comprendre
pourquoi et ce que çà leur fait, dans leur tête et dans leur vie
et ce qui est formidable, c'est que
tu lèves de l'enthousiasme avec çà.
Juste en faisant notre taff de journaliste, en faisant notre taff de
réa, en faisant notre taff d'auteur on lève de l'enthousiasme
et c'est un enthousiasme qui est agissant.
Donc çà pousse des gens à agir.
Et il y a quelque temps, j'aurais probablement été dans un pessimisme proche de celui d'Henri,
et il m'arrive.
- (H) Pas toujours *brouhaha*
- (S) Dans l'hémisphère droit d'Henri, dans l'hémisphère pessimiste.
Mais en fait, j'ai conscience des enjeux.
Et j'ai d'autant plus conscience des enjeux que, comme je m'occupe de l'enquête
je me baffre de trucs extrêmement négatifs,
et que après, avec Julien, il m'apporte encore plus de trucs négatifs.
Mais, j'ai conscience des enjeux. Par contre,
j'ai aussi cette conscience, Julien parlait de lutte,
pour moi la lutte elle est culturelle.
J'ai pris une claque dans la g***le en découvrant
les réflexions de Gramsci sur, finalement, le fait que
si tu veux émanciper des gens,
émanciper, pas dans le sens leur dire quoi penser à la place de ce qu'ils pensent parce qu'ils pensent mal.
Non. Leur apprendre à faire émerger en eux-même
la conscience de leur pouvoir d'agir
et d'agir pour leur propre bien,
mais qui sera un bien commun. Et là-dedans,
les réflexions autour de la démocratie aujourd'hui,
je pense que c'est le meilleur moment, les élections présidentielles
pour se battre les c***lles de la démocratie institutionnelle.
C'est à dire que je pense que le meilleur moment,
là, pour se dire bah
plutôt que d'aller voter pour un mec qu'on ne va jamais croiser,
qui ne va jamais te consulter, demander ton avis,
c'est le meilleur moment pour aller dans des quartiers
avec des gens qu'on n'interroge jamais,
à qui on ne parle jamais, auxquels on ne demande jamais ce qu'ils pensent.
Dans des zones rurales, dans des bassins ouvriers,
dans des zones isolées etc... Et leur demander juste
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ? Et comment on peut vous aider à le faire ? Et çà,
je trouve çà extraordinaire. Il y a des gens,
un collectif comme Pas sans nous,
qui essaient de créer à côté de la démocratie institutionnelle, une démocratie
d'interpellation, d'action. Cela me fascine.
Et je suis positif et optimiste
dans la mesure où je vois là-dedans
un esprit d'internet, mais sur le terrain aussi. Internet c'est très bien,
pour s'organiser.
Mais il y a un moment où il faut se voir.
Et se voir, aujourd'hui,
c'est à mon sens le truc le plus révolutionnaire que tu puisses faire.
C'est te foutre autour d'une table,
avec des gens que tu connais ou pas,
et leur dire : c'est quoi notre problème commun ?
et comment on peut le résoudre ensemble ? Et çà, cette notion
de collaboration et de faire émerger
les problèmes, puis les solutions ensemble,
je trouve çà tellement riche, je trouve çà tellement fort.
- (TKW) Tu sais comment on appelle çà, chez les hackers, quand on se retrouve en physique ?
- (H) De quoi ? Les heu...
- (TKW) Le maetspace.
l'espace viande.
- (H) Oui, tout à fait. D'être IRL, bien voilà. De créer des
jury participatifs, de créer de l'action,
de faire du community organizing.
- (TKW) Alors, trois petites questions encore.
L'auto-censure chez les journalistes.
Est-ce qu'il y a de l'auto-censure chez vous ?
Comment faire pour améliorer la profession de journaliste ?
- (DTG) Petite question ! Oui tranquille ! Vous répondez en deux minutes !
- (TKW) C'est de la faute du caméraman-réalisateur derrière moi, là !
- (H) Non, mais pour le coup, l'auto-censure, c'est, de mon point de vue, LE problème de la presse
avant tout. Pour avoir été dans des rédactions,
et avoir beaucoup de confrères avec qui j'échange,
le coup de Monsieur Dassault qui passe un coup de téléphone et qui dit :
vous pouvez me corriger le troisième paragraphe sur la deuxième page ?
Parce que çà me plait pas. Cà, c'est
marginal. C'est ultra marginal.
La plupart du temps, c'est un journaliste
qui a peur d'être...
- (J) Les trois quarts du temps çà se sait...
* brouhaha d'acquièscement*
- (H) Et la pire des auto-censures, c'est :
vous allez voir David Pujadas ou Jean-Michel Apathie, et vous lui dites :
mais David, Jean-Michel, la dette
c'est pas si grave. C'est pas
si grave que çà. Il y a d'autres problèmes à côté.
Ils vous regardent dans les yeux et ils vous disent :
mais bien sûr que si, c'est le plus grave des trucs qui arrivent en France aujourd'hui.
Là tu te dis, mais p*** ! La COP21, la pauvreté,
le développement de certaines maladies liées aux perturbateurs endocriniens, tout çà !
Et non. Ils en sont persuadés ! Et pour moi, c'est çà le pire ! C'est que
tu as des journalistes qui finissent par être tellement enferrés dans çà,
dans cette auto-censure, qu'ils finissent par y croire.
- (J) Ils sont convaincus. Il y a une conviction.
- (H) Il a y un dogme
- (S) C'est çà le problème. Une idéologie.
Eux, ils sont dogmatiques. Voilà. Là, il y a du dogmatisme.
- (J) Voilà. Il faut revaloriser une peu le questionnement, le doute, le rattage
le truc de se dire : on peut se planter dans une interview, poser la mauvaise question,
- (H) Interroger ce que l'on croit savoir.
Ils ne le font jamais çà.
- (S) L'humilité ! L'humilité !
- (J) Mais attention, çà ne sort pas de nulle part. Je veux dire, ce truc là, c'est pas parce que
eux, ils sont... On a pu être confronté aux mêmes problèmes, aux mêmes logiques.
Moi, il y a un truc dans lequel j'ai eu du mal à rentrer,
et ce qui fait que j'en suis sorti quand j'ai pu bosser sur des médias comme France Inter etc...
C'est l'urgence permanente de la quotidienne en fait.
Et cette urgence permanente,
je sais que moi je n'arrive pas à la gérer.
Je ne peux pas accepter des boulots comme çà
parce que çà ne me laisse pas le temps de penser
le sujet que je traite en fait.
Donc, nécessairement, enfin logiquement, mécaniquement,
tu finis par aller vers le plus simple,
le plus raccourci, le plus rabattu
*brouhaha*
et voilà, et à un moment donné, c'est naturel de poser ces questions là
sans aller plus loin. Parce que juste, tu n'as pas le temps d'aller plus loin en fait.
Et je trouve que ce dont on aurait besoin,
c'est de libérer un peu ce temps-là. D'ouvrir de l'espace-temps.
Et du temps de réflexion.
- (TKW) Tu veux rajouter un mot Henri ?
- (H) Non, pas du tout, je me passais la main dans les cheveux. Sans aucune raison.
Mais c'est un truc qui est arrivé, moi çà me reste gravé.
On a fait une projection pour le 82 minutes, le documentaire de 82 minutes
qu'on a fait. On a fait une projection Place de la République,
de plusieurs Datagueule, et on a discuté toute la journée avec des gens
qui étaient là, qui regardaient les épisodes, et avec qui on discutait.
C'était fascinant comme discussions.
- (H) On filmait pendant ce temps-là, pour donner la parole aux citoyens.
Et parmi ces discussions là, à un moment donné je discutais avec deux jeunes
qui étaient étudiants en socio
On disait : mais c'est quand même dingue ce problème écologique... machin... oui mais alors
comment on arrive à trouver les solutions... mais
mais en même temps, on est obligés de partir en rendez-vous, on a pas le temps en fait.
En fait, cela voudrait dire que si on veut faire évoluer la société,
il faut qu'on arrive à libérer du temps pour penser.
- (H) De base.
- (J) Non mais. Et là, ils m'ont dit çà, et je me suis dit : mais en fait,
c'est évident. Comment on peut faire bouger une société ?
Comment on peut demander à des électeurs d'être avertis
et de s'investir dans la démocratie
si on leur fout des journées
*brouhaha*
- (THW) Le simple et court. Passeport pour le slogan idéologique pure.
- (J) Le simple et court ?
- (TKW) Oui. C'est Frédéric Lordon qui dit çà.
- (S) Ha oui. Mais c'est à l'opposé de la vie tout çà.
- (TKW) Henri tu me sauves *rires*
- (TKW) Dernière question. Tu es très à la bourre toi ? Ou...
- (S) Je ne sais pas quelle heure il est ?
- (J) Il est 4 heures et quart.
- (TKW) 18 heures 58 *rires*
- (S) Vas-y vas-y.
- (TKW) C'est bon ?
- (S) Oui.
- (TKW) Ca c'est notre dernière question, c'est ce qu'on...
- (S) La dernière de l'émission. Après vous arrêtez, c'est fini.
- (TKW) Ca dépend. Si c'est une bonne réponse, on pourra peut-être te reposer d'autres questions.
Heum...
C'est une bouteille à la mer qu'on laisse sur internet.
C'est un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
C'est à dire que, autant un diplomate, qu'un chef d'entreprise
ou que ce soit un journaliste, il a la même question à la fin.
Laissez une bouteille à la mer
pour les jeunes générations sur internet.
Je vous écoute. Henri ?
- (H) Je commence toujours. Je finirai pour cette fois-ci.
Vas-y, commence.
- (S) J'ai déjà commencé moi. Donc, c'est toi qui commence.
- (J) Heum...
Il faut assumer la complexité, je crois.
Je crois que c'est çà. Moi, ce que j'aurai tendance à dire
aux jeunes générations, c'est que
c'est pas compliqué, mais c'est complexe.
Ce qui veut dire que c'est pas
compliqué, mais c'est plein de petits mécanismes simples
mais qu'il faut prendre le temps de les ouvrir.
Et çà peut même être fun. C'est à dire que c'est comme des petits trucs qu'on ouvre.
On se dit tiens ! C'est marrant, çà fait çà ! Voilà.
Il faut prendre ce plaisir là.
Il faut prendre le plaisir de la complexité. Je crois que c'est un truc qu'il faut assumer
et apprendre.
Si on peut l'apprendre dès le plus jeune âge, c'est cool en fait. Cà nous aide.
- (S) Moi, je dirais
il n'y a rien de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui de positif
dans nos sociétés et tout çà,
qui a une époque n'était considéré comme impossible.
Donc, c'est la fameuse expression
comment est-ce qu'on mange un éléphant ?
Une cuillère à la fois.
Et s'informer,
- (S) Ho ! Il est végétarien.
*rires* (S) En l'occurrence.
S'informer,
informer les autres,
débattre et faire jaillir les solutions
de nos contradictions, mais le faire ensemble.
Ne pas rester dans son coin. Je pense que
la tentation d'internet, c'est la tentation de se dire qu'à soi-seul
on aura la sagesse.
La tentation. Je n'ai pas dit l'attente.
La tentation d'internet, c'est de se dire
je peux acquérir cette sagesse par moi-même.
Il y a des outils pour acquérir une partie de la sagesse,
mais la sagesse n'existe qu'ensemble.
Et ensemble, il y a
tout ce qu'on a construit de positif dans cette société,
on l'a construit ensemble. Il n'y a pas un mec tout seul
qui a changé quoi que ce soit.
- (TKW) Qui disait "ensemble tout est possible", déjà ?
- (S) Je ne sais pas. Mais *rires* seul on va plus vite,
mais ensemble on va plus loin.
Je sais, c'est un proverbe malien. Je n'y suis pour rien, m*** !
- (J) J'ajouterai juste à la complexité,
c'est que la complexité, elle entraîne la nuance.
Et voilà. C'est essentiel.
- (S) Pentone !
- (H) Moi, ma petite bouteille. Mais en fait je prolonge la leur,
parce que finalement, on s'est donnés ensemble sur Datagueule pas pour rien complètement, donc
oui, bien sûr, vive la complexité.
Aimer la complexité et se méfier des bonimenteurs
et des réponses faciles, se méfier des dogmes
se méfier des gens qui savent à notre place.
Qui pré-pensent le monde à notre place.
Et pour penser le monde, il faut d'abord l'éprouver.
Aller croiser les gens, croiser les autres, aller ailleurs.
Apprécier l'altérité.
Ce qui nous bouleverse, nous transforme, nous change
parce que c'est différent.
Et l'altérité,
qui est plus vaste que la différence.
La différence, c'est une notion un peu étroite finalement.
L'altérité, c'est vraiment tout ce qui nous remplit d'autre-chose.
Heureusement. Puisque seul...
On n'est pas très intéressant, tout seul dans son coin.
C'est la multitude...
- (S) C'est pour çà qu'on est trois.
Voilà. Oui, complètement.
- (TKW) Pour notre communauté, pour résumer un peu tout çà,
on partage de temps en temps un slogan publicitaire d'une compagnie de bus
qui dit "c'est plus intelligent de voyager en groupe".
On vous conseille d'aller voir ce truc-là, çà décrit parfaitement
ce que vous venez de décrire. Vous voulez ajouter quelque chose ?
- (H) Je te remercie.
- (TKW) C'est bon ?
- Bien merci, c'est gentil pour l'invitation.
- (TKW) Alors, vous avez une question à nous poser ?
- (H) Vous faites quoi, en fait ? Ca sert à quoi tout çà ?
Pourquoi des caméras ? Pourquoi des questions ?
- (S) La présence de Morandini derrière, c'était obligatoire ?
- (TKW) Hooo nooon ! On a pas Morandini derrière ! *rires collectifs*
Pourquoi on fait çà ?
Heum...
Parce que on en avait assez de voir émerger des
nouveaux gouroux sur internet
tant les anciens, qui étaient pour nous, ou qui sont pour nous les journalistes
ou les nouveaux gouroux qui ont émergé avec
la crise financière.
Les gens qui se sont emparés, un petit peu de
notre internet.
Et on avait décidé de
sortir pour montrer qu'on pouvait faire des choses simples
avec très peu de moyens et de poser des questions en direct aux gens.
Pour aborder le sujet face à face, à la loyale.
Et on a décidé de le faire pour le bien commun de l'internet.
- (S) Et c'est qui la personne que vous aimeriez avoir
le plus et que, pour l'instant vous n'avez pas réussi ?
- (TKW) Alors. Là où on s'est pris des vestes,
on va tout vous raconter, les gars.
Alors on a pris des vestes avec l'ambassadrice américaine,
- (H) Elle est chiante, elle est chiante.
- (TKW) Comme on est des petits malins, on s'est...
On a un petit peu travaillé au corps la standardiste
qui a l'air très charmante, très polie, et qui parle un français parfait.
Qui nous a expliqué que Madame l'ambassadrice avait des notions de français
limitées. Qu'elle ne pourrait pas subir une interview de une heure face à une chaîne Youtube
de hackeurs très sourcés et...
- (H) non montée de surcroît.
- (TKW) Non montée, exactement. Et surtout, on ne donne pas les questions à l'avance.
Bon, il faut dire qu'on ne les a pas nous-même donc...
*rires*
- (S) Cà aide vachement.
- (TKW) Donc, la première veste c'est celle-ci.
L'ambassade de Chine, on n'a pas de nouvelles.
*rires*
Le site internet de l'ambassade de Chine est à la hauteur de leur envie de communiquer
avec nous, français. C'est à dire : à l'abandon.
- (H) Pour un hackeur, c'est un peu compliqué quand même.
- (TKW) Oui. Et puis... Non, c'est les seules vestes qu'on s'est tapés.
Si, il y a Jean-Luc Mélanchon qui nous fait trainer un peu depuis quatre mois et demi.
- (S) Mais les gens que tu aimerais rencontrer, toi ?
Enfin que vous ! L'équipe aussi.
- (TKW) On ne se refuse rien.
En fait, on peut avoir pratiquement qui on veut.
- (H) C'est vivant tout çà. C'est bien.
- (TKW) On se donne toujours les moyens de saisir ce qu'on veut.
- (J) C'est quoi votre vision du futur ?
- (TKW) *rire* Non, on avait dit une question.
- (J) Oh, on est trois. Une question chacun !
- (TKW) Notre vision du futur ?
- (H) Proche, moyen terme, long terme s'il vous plait.
- (TKW) Bon on va essayer de résumer çà... Ha ils me prennent heu... *rires*
Tous les voyants, toutes nos sondes
sociétales sont à l'écarlate.
La soutenabilité sociétale sur les ressources,
sur l'augmentation des violences,
sur l'incapacité des états à communiquer d'une façon diplomatique
ouverte.
Donc c'est compliqué sur cette partie là.
On voit, comme vous, l'émergence de nouveaux phénomènes collaboratifs.
qu'on essaye, soit de pousser, soit d'éclairer,
soit de backer
avec nos petits moyens.
Mais on a quand même la puissance de l'internet
avec nous, donc çà nous...
çà nous rassure. Je parle sous votre contrôle les gars hein.
Et comment on voit le futur ? Dur.
Nous, on est un petit peu des passagers clandestins parce qu'on est très privilégié.
On a une situation professionnelle qui ne connait pas encore la crise.
Et c'est pour cela qu'on fait ça bénévolement.
Mais le futur va être heu...
Tendu.
- (J) Pour le nouvel internet, pour le futur ?
- (TKW) Il y a un nouvel internet ? Ca veut dire quoi ?
- (J) Ben, est-ce qu'il faut le transformer ? Est-ce qu'il s'est transformé ? Est-ce qu'il faut le transformer ?
Parce que tu dis "heureusement on a internet"
- (TKW) Est-ce qu'on aura le temps de le transformer ?
- (J) En fait, la question c'est plus le web, mais...
- (H) Un autre web peut-être. Libéré des...
- (TKW) Oui l'interconnexion des réseaux.
Nous, on le fait tous les jours.
On a des réseaux très transverses.
Donc on arrive à avoir qui on veut.
Pour discuter du futur, de l'avenir et des conseils pour les jeunes générations.
Bon vous avez fini de nous cuisiner là ?
On refera une émission si vous voulez une prochaine fois
en tous les cas, merci d'être venus nous voir.
Vous avez été parfaits de A à Z
Ca s'est goupillé d'une façon parfaite.
Des communications rapides comme on aime.
- (S) Une ponctualité totale.
- (TKW) Tout le monde dans une même boucle, c'était super sympa.
Au nom de l'équipe, merci. C'était cool.
- (DTG) Merci à vous.